hey guys i'm ryan wright i'm dan cyber
we're gonna watch the trailer today the
gameplay trailer for a little game that
i forgot the title to dead island 2
sunshine and slaughter gameplay that's
what we're watching today the e3 trailer
was [ __ ] dope is that the one with
the guy running and his skin's falling
off yeah he slowly turns into a zombie
that's awesome yeah that was a cool
trailer very creative trailer very
grateful i did a lot um yeah i wanna i
wanna watch this what are we doing why
are we talking shut up
shut up
shut up dan
don't make me whip out my belt sometimes
you gotta put a white man in check you
know what i mean
peggy 18.
okay
it's fair it's important to note
still looks great
oh
yes
oh my god this is
so much fun i love the weapon choices
i love this so much so [ __ ] violent i
love it
oh my god
dude hell yeah i will pre-order that
because i want all of that
i really want to play that so fast it
just looks like some of the most fun of
all time oh my god i mean once again
brings up are the controls gonna be easy
enough to pull off half of that [ __ ]
yeah but i'm still so game for
everything that just happened dude it
looks like just such a blast i mean the
different weapons you could use are just
so exciting to get your hands on in the
walking dead they usually use like
weapons to kill them with rather than
just shooting them in the head
so i like the idea of being able to get
close to a zombie and just kill them in
that way because they're not running
after you they're slow as zombies which
makes me really exciting i'm really i'm
really excited to play it looks like
kill bill was [ __ ] awesome because of
how [ __ ] violent it was and this
looks like the same reason too i really
want to play this also this looked great
for pre-alpha
gameplay it looked real i would buy it
based off how it looked yeah i mean i'm
really excited to see like once it's
like fully built and fully developed how
good it's gonna look so i'm stoked yeah
i'm i do oh god yes great way to start
off our night yeah great
this is special this was a good decision
this is a special moment we have right
here
let's treasure this
are you
i'm burying the treasure oh you're
burying the treasure i thought you're
doing some catholic ritual jokes anyway
guys thanks for letting me know that
trailer was out uh if you're new to this
channel you know you can do you can
subscribe to the real rejects that would
be [ __ ] cool that'd be awesome and
dan has a gaming channel you should
subscribe to his channel too yeah it's
an awesome [ __ ] channel
really i like your channel i approve of
your channel
yes
right approved and if you're new to the
channel
um we usually like to take this moment
to in a way give me start this over so
i'm not like rubbing my eyes no we we'd
like to keep this footage raw
okay just
[ __ ] all right fine it's raw it's raw
i'm just saying on your channel
yes i would [ __ ] do that okay you
come on this channel dan you're gonna
[ __ ] play by my rules
you understand yeah
do you understand yeah
jesus
the [ __ ] is up with you tonight anyway
gsb zero nine zero two two two zero zero
could you maybe
get
elissa sally or jerry to give me a shout
out i don't mind who it is who says it
i'd really appreciate it well you're not
any of those people you're not but he
said he doesn't mind as long as someone
says his name i've said it so dan can
you please say his name gsb
oh zero
niner zero two two zero zero zero thanks
for subscribing to the channel thank you
you will beat you you have been uh your
views
really add to my paycheck
thank you
i probably shouldn't talk about my
paycheck should i no
[ __ ]
i keep this raw though
youtube rip folks everything if you
mention money be emanuel neves oh hello
he wants a shout out well b emanuel
neves
interesting interesting name what does
the b stand for
brandon
bradley
or of course the obvious one that we're
all thinking bartholomew [ __ ] oh does
it stand for [ __ ] emmanuel neves you
want to be my [ __ ] i'd like you to be
my [ __ ] for a night
you know what you know why these shout
outs turn into this
because of
[ __ ] like porn live events uh what
that's when you like you know people are
having sex but it's live and then people
can like
request or call in and stuff and then
you tell them what to do and they'll do
it
this isn't live though
i know i know but that's why my shout
outs turn into something perverted oh
because i'm used to being like yeah ryan
you
got a big dick
what happens on this couch
what i just told you
well you got me to realize something b
manuel you're a good [ __ ] slade wilson
dude holy [ __ ] what a name
do an irish accent and give me a shout
out slade wilson you my friend are a
good lad
porcupines i don't know anything about
irish people potatoes oh you got a
really scary name there
slade dude what a [ __ ] badass name
how much [ __ ] do you get with that
that's not your real name change it
right away i hope you go out and kick
ass on a bit on like a nightly basis
just like some person like said
something wrong to someone and then you
like show up and you're like hey you
take that back he's like make me and
then you like chest kick them and like
concaves in because if you break the
sternum if you break if you break the
sternum like the ribs
go in
so
i think slade just goes around like
chest kicks people they know
and that's when someone goes
who the hell was that
then there's us that's slade
just like they're in an alleyway they
just got saved by slade and then us at
the end that was slayed yeah
welcome
he's not the hero we deserve but the one
we need